Netflix's October line-up is bursting with
gory goodness to usher in Halloween.
But the streaming workhorse isn't a one-trick
pony, so you can also fill up on brand new
comedy, action, drama, and new seasons of
your favorite TV shows, including the hotly
anticipated Stranger Things season two.
Here's everything coming to Netflix in October
2017.
Rodney Carrington: Here Comes the Truth
Musician-comedian Rodney Carrington has made
a name for himself through his crude stand-up
infused with country music ballads, and he's
been touring again in summer 2017 with his
brand new routine, Here Comes the Truth.
If you haven't been able to see Carrington's
show live, it's coming as a Netflix exclusive
on October 3.
The Bonus Family: Season 1
This popular Swedish series was earmarked
for global distribution by Netflix in early
2017 and rebranded as a Netflix original everywhere
outside of Sweden, marking another fantastic
foreign acquisition that, let's be honest,
nobody else would ever have heard of if not
for the streaming service.
The dramedy series centers on four divorcees
who find new spouses...and new step-children.
Only, in Sweden, step-mothers and step-fathers
are actually called "bonus moms" and "bonus
dads."
Netflix picked up distribution rights for
the first two seasons, so while only the first
season is dropping on October 5, chances are
you'll be able to find the second season on
Netflix sometime soon afterward.
The Death and Life of Marsha P. Johnson
For those who don't know, Marsha P. Johnson
was an activist and transgender woman who
was an instrumental figure in the gay rights
movement for decades.
On July 6, 1992, her body was found floating
in the Hudson River, sparking one of the most
hotly debated investigations in recent history.
Although police initially ruled Johnson's
death a suicide, public outcry and a steadily
mounting pile of evidence forced police to
reopen her case in 2012 to determine if she
had, in reality, been murdered and dumped
in the river.
The new Netflix documentary The Death and
Life of Marsha P. Johnson takes a hard look
at that investigation and the circumstances
leading up to Johnson's untimely death.
Queue it up on October 6.
Suburra Season 1
This crime thriller marks Netflix's first
Italian-language original series, but don't
let the subtitles hold you back — this series
looks to be packed with criminal intrigue,
political corruption, and all the dirty laundry
you'd expect from a mob story set in the heart
of Rome.
The series will serve as a prequel to the
2015 film of the same name, and if it's anywhere
near as good as that movie, Suburra may become
a modern crime classic.
Plus, because it's a prequel, it's a safe
bet that viewers will be able to jump in even
if they haven't seen the movie.
The first season drops October 6.
Christina P: Mother Inferior
Comedian Christina Pazsitzky has been making
waves in the stand-up scene lately, although
she's still probably best known for her podcast,
Your Mom's House.
Hopefully, her Netflix stand-up special Mother
Inferior, which premieres on October 10, will
change that and introduce Pazsitzky to a wider
audience.
Fe de Etarras
October seems to be the month for foreign-language
originals.
In addition to Suburra, Netflix is premiering
Fe de Etarras, a Spanish comedy film about
an unlikely group of people stuck in an apartment
waiting for a mysterious phone call.
That's about as vague of a premise as you're
likely to find, but if you're in the mood
for something a little outside the box, you
can queue up Fe de Etarras when it hits Netflix
worldwide on October 12.
Kingdom of Us
Take a step inside small-town America with
Kingdom of Us, a poignant documentary chronicling
the shattered lives of seven siblings whose
world was torn apart when their father committed
suicide.
Through candid interviews and home videos,
Kingdom of Us pieces together the bond this
family shared with their father and the long
road ahead of them as they try to deal with
the tragedy of his loss.
It's guaranteed to be an emotional, painful
ride, but there may just be hope on the horizon.
Experience all the highs and lows alongside
the Shanks family on October 13.
Mindhunter: Season 1
From creator Joe Penhall, Mindhunter is an
all-new Netflix original that follows FBI
profiler Holden Ford, played by Jonathan Groff,
as he gets inside the heads of serial killers
to bring them to justice.
The series premiere is directed by David Fincher,
virtually ensuring a dark, twisted kick-off
to a series that dives into the minds of the
most notorious psychopaths of the 20th century.
Holt McCallany and Fringe's Anna Torv co-star.
Get ready to binge on the insanity when the
first season hits on October 13.
Voltron: Legendary Defender Season 4
Just two months after Season 3 hit Netflix,
the streaming service is bringing in the fourth
season of its hit animated series Voltron:
Legendary Defender.
The same cast returns to voice the colorful
Paladins of Voltron, and the season four picks
up right where the third left off, with the
team of heroes working to stop their nemesis'
evil plan.
Check in for more of the fast-paced action
on October 13.
The Meyerowitz Stories
So far, Adam Sandler's Netflix films haven't
done much to impress either critics or audiences,
but that streak may end with The Meyerowitz
Stories, which sees Sandler headlining once
again with a supporting cast that includes
Dustin Hoffman, Emma Watson, and Ben Stiller,
to name a few.
With writer/director Noah Baumbach of The
Squid and the Whale at the helm, we're hoping
this installment in the Sandlerverse will
play the laughs more low key than some of
Sandler's previous films and deliver a compelling
story at the same time.
So far, early critical response has been overwhelmingly
favorable.
Check it out on October 13.
The Babysitter
Netflix's original horror comedy The Babysitter
follows a 12-year-old boy named Cole who finds
out that his super hot babysitter happens
to be a satanic killer.
And now that Cole knows her secret, he'll
have to kill or be killed to survive the night.
Directed by McG from a script by Brian Duffield,
The Babysitter premieres on Friday, October
13.
Patton Oswalt: Annihilation
You've got to love Patton Oswalt, and the
affable everyman is back on October 17 with
a new one-hour stand-up special.
In Annihilation, Oswalt gets more personal
than ever before as he works the pain and
loss of his wife's recent passing into a new,
intimate stand-up set.
If you want to see Patton Oswalt as you've
never seen him, tune in for Annihilation and
be prepared for both laughs and tears along
the way.
The Day I Met El Chapo: The Kate del Castillo
Story
Told as a three-part mini-series, The Day
I Met El Chapo chronicles the fateful interview
between one of history's most vicious drug
lords and A-list Mexican actress Kate del
Castillo.
Castillo will star in the series as well as
produce, and the documentary will draw from
real-life footage of the meeting and the planning
in the days and weeks leading up to the interview
with the cartel kingpin.
Get a closer look at the true story on October
20.
Wheelman
Strap in for high-stakes action and an adrenaline-filled
thrill ride when Wheelman drops on Netflix
on October 20.
Starring Frank Grillo as the wheelman in the
title, the story centers on a driver for a
band of bank robbers who gets double crossed
on a job.
With the lives of his family at stake, he'll
stop at nothing to find the truth and bring
the backstabber to justice.
It's kill or be killed, and hopefully this
feature film debut from writer/director Jeremy
Rush will deliver all the pulse-pounding action
promised in the Wheelman trailer.
Between his Castle Rock series, a Mist series,
The Dark Tower, Netflix's Gerald's Game, and
— oh yeah — It, Stephen King is experiencing
a big-screen resurgence in a big way.
King's next story to hit Netflix is 1922,
starring Thomas Jane as a rancher in the early
20th century who convinces his son to help
him murder his wife.
If the film takes the same cues as the source
novella, 1922 will hopefully turn out to be
a tense thriller fused with paranoia of the
worst kind.
Check it out on October 20.
Haters Back Off: Season 2
Based on a YouTube channel called Miranda
Sings, created by Colleen Ballinger, Haters
Back Off is a satirical look at YouTube fame
and everyone who wants a piece of that pie
— with or without any discernible talent.
This Netflix original first hit the streaming
service in 2016 and stars Ballinger in a continuation
of her YouTube persona, Miranda Sings, a self-centered,
eccentric girl who thinks she's good at everything...when
she really isn't.
Look for season 2 on October 20.
One of Us
This documentary certainly comes with an interesting
premise: it's about three Hasidic Jews living
in a strict religious community in New York
who decide to leave that world behind.
Abandoning everything they've ever known,
they face hate and violence from both the
outside world and their former community.
One of Us promises to be a slicing portrait
of religious intolerance and the struggle
to live with all the cards stacked against
you.
Look for it on October 20.
Joan Didion: The Center Will Not Hold
Novelist, journalist, and screenwriter Joan
Didion became the voice of the counter-culure
through her stories and essays published throughout
the '60s and '70s, all the way up to the present
day.
The documentary The Center Will Not Hold travels
back in time across Didion's extraordinary
life to explore how a young writer became
a pop culture icon — and literary legend.
Take the ride on October 27.
Stranger Things: Season 2
After a groundbreaking first season followed
by a painful year-long wait, Stranger Things
is finally back with season two, and things
promise to get even hairier in the Upside
Down this time around.
Executive producer Shawn Levy told Variety
that the stakes are even higher in our next
visit to the town of Hawkins, as if we needed
any more incentive to tune in when Stranger
Things season two drops October 27.
Judah Friedlander: America is the Greatest
Country in the United States
With his deadpan delivery, ironic punchlines,
and big, shaggy beard, Judah Friedlander is
definitely a unique face in the stand-up world,
although most people likely know him best
from his role as Frank in 30 Rock.
Friedlander's new stand-up special, America
is the Greatest Country in the United States,
takes a stab at the American way of life,
lampooning everything from racism to foreign
policy.
According to Friedland, the special will premiere
on Netflix on October 31, although Netflix
maintains that it will air on the 30th.
Either way, it'll arrive just in time to help
you ease those late-night jitters after all
those horror movies you'll probably be watching
this month.
New Movies
It wouldn't be a proper October without a
new lineup of horror and thriller movies,
and Netflix is bringing in some brand-new
shockers like 13 Demons, The Survivalist,
and Cult of Chucky, out October 3, followed
by 2017's cannibal thriller Raw the day after.
For more down-to-earth thrills, this month
is seeing the addition of Blood Diamond and
Stanley Kubrick's Eyes Wide Shut, both of
which arrive October 1.
Additionally, Donnie Darko arrives October
11th, and Quentin Tarantino's The Hateful
Eight is shooting for an October 25 premiere.
For more casual viewing, look for the addition
of several cult classic comedies, like 1996's
Don’t Be a Menace to South Central While
Drinking Your Juice in the Hood.
"Do.
We.
Have.
A. Problem.
Huh?"
On top of that, Netflix is bringing in Eagle
vs Shark, an offbeat indie comedy directed
by Taika Waititi and starring Jermaine Clement,
the same comedic duo who brought us What We
Do in the Shadows.
Both films arrive October 1, along with I
Love You, Man, Tommy Boy, and both Miss Congeniality
movies.
Netflix's documentary game has been off the
charts lately, and October is set to continue
that trend.
On October first, look for Generation Iron,
Ice Guardians, and Tokyo Idols.
Later in the month, get your music fix with
back-to-back biopics Mr. Dynamite: The Rise
of James Brown and Chris Brown: Welcome to
My Life, premiering on October 2 and 7, respectively.
Finally, what's Halloween without family time?
For the younger generation of trick-or-treaters,
Netflix is bringing on such family fare as
A Cinderella Story: Once Upon a Song, Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory, and 2017's Smurfs:
The Lost Village, to name a few.
New Television
Stranger Things may be the highlight of Netflix's
new series, but that doesn't mean there won't
be plenty of other new shows and seasons to
binge in the coming month.
Highlights include season two of Cleverman
on October 1, season three of Schitt's Creek
on October 5, and the first season of the
serial adaptation of Stephen King's The Mist
on October 24, which follows new characters
caught in the same mysterious mist that terrorized
the cast of the 2007 film.
Also arriving on October 24 are the first
two seasons of Wanted, the acclaimed Australian
drama series about two strangers who find
themselves drawn together during a murder
investigation.
"He's never going to stop chasing us."
"There's no way out!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!